So, the course would cost 4,200 dollars...
...and that's for the design and then to run it for the two groups.
That's a little bit more than we have budgeted for.
Is there any way you could reduce it just a little bit?
Well, I think it is a good price.
Maybe if we had an agreement that you would have 12 people or fewer on each course,...
...that would save me a little bit of cost.
I could do it for 4,100 then.
It's still a little bit high.
What if we were to book this date for several programs spread over the next two years?
How much cheaper would that be?
Well, running it several times would bring the cost down a little bit.
If you book three, I could bring it down to 3,840.
But, if you wanted to bring it down a bit more, I had an idea.
If you could refer to me on your website, recommend me on there,...
...and if I could refer to you on my website as a customer,...
...then I could bring it down to 3,660. How about that?
Okay, what if we were to provide you with all of the printing...
....and gave you a really great lunch every day?
What would be the absolute best you could do it for?
Well, the lunch would be nice.
The printing doesn't make a lot of difference to my costs.
But, I suppose it would make it a little bit cheaper to run.
So, if you did the printing and provided the lunch as well,...
...then I could bring it down to 3,620.
How about we go ahead on that basis?
That's a good deal.
Let's do it.
Excellent.